j'ai eu une enfance assez solitaire
parce que j'étais l'aînée de très loin
mes parents et mon frère beaucoup plus
tard que moi
et donc et donc j'étais l'aînée j'étais
donc assez solitaire et alors tous mes
petits cousins j'avais l'habitude de
leur faire jouer des pièces de théâtre
j'écrivais des pièces de théâtre et je
leur montrais des pièces de théâtre et
voilà je vous avais toujours le
spectacle oui oui à l'époque je rêvais
d'être actrice et puis je me suis rendu
compte que j'avais pas le talent alors
je me suis orienté vers la zone
d'attenté à 6,6 ici j'ai essayé le
théâtre amateur mais j'étais pas assez
jolie il y avait beaucoup de filles
beaucoup plus jolie pour jouer déjà deux
premières un coup de jeune première
non c'est vrai c'est vrai il ya aussi
les servantes
est ce qu'il reste un peu de comédienne
en vous dans ce théâtre politique
valérie pécresse je crois que la
politique c'est pas de la comédie et je
crois que c'est pas c'est pas être
acteur je crois que la politique c'est
c'est des convictions je crois que la
politique c'est de l'action et c'est
très différent de jouer un rôle du
paraître comme dans la politique il ya
de la séduction il ya dû plaire mais à
trop plaire on oublie de faire et moi je
suis une femme qui fait
[Musique]